I figure we'll run the 21st century not
in the sense of being the most powerful
economic bloc in the world all the most
powerful military bloc in the world but
what I argued him in my book is that the
European way of doing things is uniquely
relevant to the area of globalization
that we've entered at the moment and I
argue that the European Union is the
maybe the most important political
innovation since the nation-state was
created 500 years ago because I think
this experiment which we see in the
European Union
it shows how countries can work together
to solve problems that cut across
borders Europeans have countries have
come together and created the biggest
single market in the world the most
advanced ways of dealing with problems
like environmental pollution organized
crime terrorism across borders and
they've done it in a way that relies on
international law rather than military
competition and and and the balance and
the balance of power between different
countries and that is a sort of
revolution in in international relations
and it's one which is both going to
become more important within Europe
itself as more and more countries join
the European Union and it it continues
to grow or really has half a billion
people but eventually could you know end
up with with many more countries in it
but also it is being copied in all other
parts of the world in Latin America
they're developing a medical surely and
Africa the African Union and even in
East Asia they're talking about building
an East Asian community mortal's on the
opinion if that happens in every part of
the world has got its own regional
unions and you see the development of
new international organizations based on
the principles with which the European
Union is run what you could see is a
European century not because you're it
runs the world like an empire but
because the European way of doing things
becomes the world's way of doing things
I both think that that is likely to
happen just because there's so many
problems that cut across borders now we
need to have fresh thinking about how we
deal with them and the opinion is the
most innovative and
flexible way of dealing with them and
secondly I think it would be a much
better world if it's run like that than
the status quo so I hope I'm right as
well I think that like a lot of imperial
projects the European Union is doomed to
carry on expanding but it's not
something which will happen in in one go
but very few people that know 120 years
ago would have predicted that there'd be
27 member states in the European Union
and it would stretch as far as you know
as places like Estonia and I I think you
know in 20 30 years time it's quite
likely that there'll be a whole new
swathe of countries in the European
Union like turkey Ukraine Moldova maybe
even Belarus one day but at the moment
just as we've seen in the past after
every time after every wave of
enlargement there's a lot of skepticism
for citizens people turn against the
idea of further expansion you know there
is a pause going on and people are quite
skeptical about it but I think there
there is a natural tendency to look
outwards because each wave of countries
that joins the European Union wants to
make sure that its neighbors get in as
well because it will make them more
peaceful more democratic and it will
increase their economic opportunities
and that's why that the people who are
keenest for the European Union to carry
on enlarging of those countries of the
periphery it's if Poland that wants
Ukrainian because it's their neighbor
that is outside I think people were
holding their breath they don't want to
you know they were slightly burnt by
their experience when Putin came in when
all European leaders rushed to Moscow to
embrace him very quickly and to show
that they had developed a special
relationship with him and then what they
found shortly afterwards was was that
Russia was pursuing a lot of policies
which weren't necessarily
that compatible with what the weather
the European ones wanted things to go
and what most European leaders are doing
now is trying to be friendly to show him
respect but to judge him by his deeds
rather than by his words and to to see
how he will develop as a as a political
leader whether he will be a kind of
mini-me of flooding net Putin or whether
he will actually live up to some of his
more liberal sounding rhetoric and the
jury's still very much out